curtis what's going on how can i help my
mom essentially is a hoarder
okay and she's 60 67 she has a 700
square foot apartment
small two-bedroom apartment and she's
just allowed it to become a disaster
zone
and uh her apartment complex is
threatening to kick her out
and she needs help i want to help her i
love my mom
you know she's not perfect she's made a
lot of mistakes but she's loved me her
my whole
life and i want to help her i want to
help her clean it out
and i want to help her with tools so it
doesn't happen again and i want to help
her get therapy and i just
i really just don't know how to approach
that i'll go about doing that
man i love you curtis um thanks for
calling thanks for loving your mom man
and hoarding is embarrassing and it's
gross and it's hard and you're doing a
brave thing leaning into that man
and i'm grateful for you dude so um
when did this kick off often hoarding
behaviors start early in somebody's life
you can trace it back but sometimes they
just
something happens there's a death in the
family there is
there is some behavior that just flips a
switch and then things pile up
like really well so
her her parents were hoarders my
grandparents okay
and so she kind of grew up in a home
like that and you know she grew up broke
her dad couldn't hold on a job
you know they she didn't know you know
where money was gonna come from
yeah if they were gonna be able to buy
groceries and clothes and so forth
so she kind of grew up in that
environment where her her
parents had that that scarcity mindset
and so they just
accumulated everything because they
didn't know where you know if they were
going to be able to buy something in the
future
and so that's that's kind of like a
script that was built into her
kind of like her subconscious i guess
but
it started for her maybe uh maybe
maybe 10 years ago
probably when she really started started
doing it herself
and what does it look like is it
newspapers and magazines and
and old food or is it a trink a specific
type of
collection that's gotten out of control
or pets what does it look like
paint a picture for me yeah yeah so it's
the magazines it's old food
um uh she she's a very avid
crocheter so she has mountains of yarn
okay
you know i'm not embellishing no i know
yarn that goes to the ceiling
yeah um and just
just old mail okay so if you go to her
house
walk me through if you knocked on her
door today and you had a buddy with you
and y'all were wearing gloves and you
said mom we're cleaning up today
what would happen she probably won't let
us in
okay she would say get out this is my
house right
okay what is she protecting herself from
she's embarrassed okay she's she's
ashamed of what's going on
she doesn't want people to judge her yep
and that that
shame leads to more cover-up behavior
which leads to more loneliness which
leads to more cover-up behavior and so
it goes right
right yeah so before i before i kind of
walk through what you can do
are you experiencing this no
not at all so you have no no hording
tendencies no hanging onto things or no
sentimental
that you feel is maybe a little bit high
a little bit a little bit on the on the
high end
no complete completely opposite you're a
minimalist right you live in a
yeah there's nothing on the walls
well my wife takes care of the walls but
i i try to have as
little as possible okay and i think i
think too because i grew up seeing my
grandparents in their house and so i saw
just how
how horrible the life that is and um
i just don't i just don't want that
happen to me yeah
okay so um you know this that
the hoarding is actually can be
considered a disorder you all know how
much
i disdain the the dsm but it's just the
excessive accumulation of objects that
lead to a mess and there's really not a
reason to have all the stuff right
there's not a reason to have
17 years of magazines and old food and
old dog food etc doesn't make it doesn't
make rational sense if you will why
these things are being kept
yeah and then number two there's an
unwillingness to part with these things
and number three is
is where where the kicker is is there's
an interference with healthy functioning
right there's an inability to have
people over that's like you talked about
that shame and then it just loops and
loops and loops and suddenly
you are trapped right so here's the
the tough news for you
true hoarding right is this
nexus of impulsivity and it sounds like
a really awful word but
neurotic is the word people's people
are are not functioning out of their
rational mind right yeah and that
impulsivity is
very very hard to treat and so
i i this is just me i've always thought
there was an anxiety ocd addiction
component to hoarding that's just me
that's just how i read some of that
literature
i haven't actually done a big deep dive
into the literature but
it's this looping i need to solve this
problem and then i'm just going to keep
this and then i get stuck on it
and then when someone tries to help me
with that then i grab even tighter so
this isn't like tv these are really hard
to treat
and you i don't know a situation
unless somebody just flips a switch
somebody can probably right into the
show and let me know of a situation i've
never heard of a situation that doesn't
require
professional intervention there are
people
there are mental health professionals
who do this work exclusively this is
what they do
and they will work with people inside
and outside exposure therapy is
is the is the top line here and what
that is is you just have to slowly teach
somebody
how to experience throwing something
away similar to
if someone's got a phobia of snakes
they'll show you a picture of a snake
and the next time you come back they'll
show you a couple of pictures of snakes
right and slowly the goal is eventually
they're going to
show you an aquarium with a snake in it
you might go to the zoo together
eventually you're going to hold a snake
right and what you're doing is you're
teaching your body that this
isn't a threat right that this isn't
gonna do the thing that your amygdala is
telling you or whatever part of your
brain is telling you is gonna happen
and so exposure therapy some cognitive
behavior therapy that's that's
that's the way that works right that's
what you gotta do but you gotta get a
professional to do that
the thing you can do and it's gonna be
mind-numbing and so hard
is to continue to let your mom know how
much you love her
and at the same time you've got to draw
really strong boundaries
right real strong boundaries meaning
you can't get drawn into that rabbit
hole right if you go
to her house while she's gone and you
just clean the whole thing
up you're going to implode a human being
right from the inside out and so
um will she come out and visit you
yeah yeah okay absolutely and does she
have that
those tendencies when she's with you or
does she able when she gets out of that
environment is she able to
um is she able to come visit visit you
yeah she gets out of the environment
yeah she's different totally different
huh
so that's a great place to start would
she go see somebody does she know this
is a problem
i know she's seen a therapist in the
past for different things
um i think she would
to see a therapist for you know what
she's what's going on now
do you live in her area i don't
know so my mom lives about four hours
away okay
all right um some of these exposure
therapies can be done in intensives
meaning a four-hour session right with
with a therapist in a group
i wonder if and this may be a
conversation for you and your wife i
wonder if y'all could
have a family therapy session with your
wife
and you and your mom if your mom felt
that was a safe situation or if you have
brothers and sisters
and the idea being this not that there's
something wrong with mom
but that you ask mom tell your mom i
want to do a better job of loving my mom
and i see you mom are struggling and i
don't have the tools to help in a way
that i want to
and so i'm going to go meet with a
counselor so i can learn some new tools
and i would love love for you to come
with me because then she can speak into
how do i love my mom better and that's
going to help me
love my wife better that's gonna help me
love my kids better but mom would you
join me
and brothers and sisters so we can get
some more tools and that might
that might encourage her to come to one
of those four hour intensives they're
expensive
and they're heavy but man they can be
healing when a family gets together that
way and remember this isn't hey mom i
want you to come down because you're
jacked up and we're gonna look
we're gonna get you healed now you were
talking about how you can get some more
tools so you can love her better
and you want her to be a part of that
process man she's gonna feel
deep shame deep regret because she grew
up in this with her parents
right and she knows what it's like to be
embarrassed that nobody can come over
she knows what it's like to be trapped
and so lonely and you can't have anyone
come over and have coffee with you
and how you're always hiding this other
part of your life how you're never gonna
find any romantic partner she knows that
she doesn't need to be hit upside the
head with it what she does need
is a gentle introduction to somebody who
is safe who can begin
to walk alongside her in a healing
journey so brother i'm so grateful that
you are one of the guys who loves his
mom
enough to keep himself well keep his
family well
and to want her to just live
the last years of her life joyfully
thriving and able to just simply move
around her apartment right things that
most of us take for granted every day